there's been days where it's been harder
for me than other days of course my
philosophy is just take each day at a
time
Britney Spears sticking true to that
message and putting her mental health
first a source close to the spears
family tells ET she is currently in a
facility taking time to care for herself
amid tremendous stress over her father
Jamie Spears is current health crisis
it's been a roller coaster according to
a different source she is the one who
finally decided she needed help and made
the decision to manage her own emotions
she finally realized it was affecting
her everyday life and even her
relationships on Wednesday Britney
shared this message on Instagram writing
we all need to take time for a little me
time
[Music]
fans and loved ones were quick to send
the pop star their support on social
media Brits boyfriend Sam took to
Instagram to praise his leading lady
reposting her post he added the caption
quote it isn't weakness it's a sign of
absolute strength people should only be
inspired by this at least I am hashtags
stronger the 37 year olds little sister
jamie-lynn also chimed in on Instagram
sharing this throwback shot and writing
she's the F and best hashtag woman crush
Wednesday Celine Dion also offered her
support to Britney during a chat with et
right now she needs courage so I'm
sending her all my courage and my inner
strength and my stability and the love
and the respect that I do have for other
artists and it's hard sometimes it's
hard but you know when you go something
hard
especially family member you find
strength within yourself that you did
not know you had I don't know her so so
so personally but after a while when you
go through something tough you come back
stronger in January Britney announced
that she was going to be taking an
indefinite Work hiatus to focus on her
father's recovery after a near-death
health incident Britney shared the news
on Instagram writing in part a couple of
months ago my father was hospitalized
and almost died we're all so grateful
that he came out of it alive but he
still has a long road ahead of him I had
to make the difficult decision to put my
full focus and energy on my family at
this time I hope you all can understand
you know you hold on to family when you
go through hard times but now a source
tells ET that his illness has frightened
Brit adding quote she has always trusted
her father in every way and is finding
it difficult to deal with a possibility
of losing him so it's important to
remember that Brittany's dad is still
her conservator meaning he continues to
be in charge of basically all decisions
in her life this all dates back
more than a decade starting in 2006 a
few months after filing for divorce from
kevin federline she checked into a rehab
facility only to check out the next day
then days later she infamously shaved
off all her hair in a salon in Los
Angeles a year later in January 2008 she
was committed to the psychiatric ward of
UCLA Medical Center and put on an
involuntary psychiatric hold and was
released in February so we here at et
are sending all of our love and support
Brittany's way she is a rock star and we
applaud her for stepping back and taking
care of herself
but of course we'll keep you up to date
on all things Brittany so be sure to
subscribe to ET until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens
[Music]